maybe because that's because I'm always
in a flow state
oh
maybe Chad opponent in the development
of the dude Z Plus streaming service
will no doubt be partnering with
well-known Brands to produce content I
have access to astonishing data that
suggests Taco Bell will be in the market
to produce a sitcom in the next three to
five years will in chat you must now
develop a sitcom and it must star
Charlie Sheen of course here's the basic
premise after a night of hard partying
Charlie Sheen's character Gorges himself
on Taco Bell the next morning he
releases a twisted heap of fecal matter
in his toilet the mixture of drugs he
took and the chemicals in the Taco Bell
items he consumed bring the fecal matter
to life and his days of being a Carefree
single guy are threatened with the
responsibility of raising his new child
this is baby doo doo brought to you by
Taco Bell begin oh man
baby doo-doo my Taco Bell so the premise
of the sitcom is that Charlie Sheen or
whatever Charlie Sheen's character uh
I'm sorry why is it always Charlie Sheen
I don't [ __ ] know dude why is any of
this always anything
uh that's true you do do a good Charlie
Sheen though thank you if you like beans
and cheese you'll love Taco Bells I
can't even do it I gotta peel the onion
a little bit Chad years ago you said
what was it the 80s or something the 90s
I think it was in the 90s he did a Taco
Bell radio ad that I remember hearing
about uh you know Taco Bell's new seven
bean and cheese burrito or something and
it just like stuck in my [ __ ] head
yeah you love beans and cheese yeah
anyway so we have to now come up with a
sitcom that is based on the premise of
Charlie Sheen is a fun-loving single guy
goes out partying takes a bunch of drugs
eats Taco Bell Taco Bell the drugs on
the Taco Bell in his stomach mix into a
turd that becomes a living child named
baby doo doo yeah it seems like he was
at a baseball Rave and probably consumed
some bad terms okay
um yeah okay let's mix it all in I love
it he did so much Terra mersalin that he
went back to a baseball Rave in 1922. no
uh Charlie Sheen does a bunch of drugs
eats Taco Bell shits out a baby baby
doo-doo this is a series for Duty plus
yes okay now usually in these kind of
series voice of Charlie Sheen like uh
animated show no I think this is live
action with a CG uh like feces baby love
it so I don't know who voices the feces
baby though
Jane Fonda
Jane Fonda
you want to hear my Jane Fonda I bet
yeah similar yeah maybe Tom Brady voices
baby Duty hi I'm I'm Tom what if uh
Alex Jones sure it's Charlie Sheen and
Alex Jones that's his [ __ ] I don't want
to be a [ __ ] baby yeah these uh
you know uh the the uh the Rockefellers
so wait a minute is the baby a full like
it has an adult mind and it's in a
conspiracy theories and [ __ ] just from
birth like it crawls out of the toilet
the next morning and it's a full formed
like it can speak and think like a
full-formed adult I'm a baby right now
let me tell you about let me tell you
about what's happening in Bohemian Grove
Daddy okay so usually in this archetype
uh it's about like a you know a single
kind of party guy who gets saddled with
a kid this is like uh Hugh Grant was in
that one uh about About a Boy tremendous
movie all of these things I mean even
Two and a Half Men to some degree is
like this when John Cryer moves in with
Charlie Sheen he's got a son and in the
pilot if I remember right Charlie Sheen
is like oh this is gonna [ __ ] totally
suck and ruin my life and then they're
out at the grocery store and a woman
comes up and sees Charlie Sheen with the
little kid and it's like oh isn't he
cute and he's like ah this is gonna work
out after all yeah so that's usually the
point lot of these this archetype but in
this case single women Alone Together
single women Alone Together that was in
uh that was in
uh About a Boy dude all right
um in this case sorry the child is made
of [ __ ] yeah so I would imagine the
child is going to repulse any potential
uh women that might be interested in
Charlie Sheen but it's a Charming turd
and I think actually it should be Tom
Brady voicing the turd okay uh it's it's
Tom Brady as a turd that's going to
bring a lot of viewers Charlie Sheen's
return to television okay he's got a
very cute turd with a Tom Brady haircut
uh who wears a little uh little Tom
Brady Jersey maybe it takes place in
Boston okay love that and he goes to uh
he goes to he's a huge Tom Brady fan the
kid he's a big yeah the kid or Charlie
Sheen the kid and I think Charlie Sheen
should hate Tom Brady I don't like Tom
Brady yeah Tom Brady's I'm a big fan of
all the other teams
he's beat the spread every time I've
lost so much money on Brady and now I've
got to take my [ __ ] my [ __ ] child my
[ __ ] had to see Brady and I think also
the [ __ ] kids should have to eat Taco
Bell for every meal or he dies
that keeps him alive so there's like
product placement throughout and Charlie
Sheen is now like God damn it we have to
eat Taco Bell again can't we eat
McDonald's can't we eat Wendy's can't we
eat Chick-fil-A he's like no dad I want
a bean and cheese burrito I'm Tom Brady
I like beans and cheese you know guess
what I'll take you to Taco Bell Tom in
about a boy he goes to uh he goes to a
single parent meeting yes dude I
remember that uh or maybe it was single
mothers alone to get single mothers
Alone Together yeah uh that's what it
was uh smat single mothers Alone
Together single mothers alone together
so he goes to a smat uh with it's uh
smat but uh you could some could say
it's scat hey everybody that's the kind
of fun we're going to be having here on
dudes FM d double o d z 10 000 on your
fm dial hey we got some Savage Garden
coming up after the Break
um uh he takes the cute turd to the
single mothers Alone Together meeting
because he does he truly like Hugh Grant
sort of intercepting this kid although
Hugh Grant in about a boy does it out of
the goodness of his heart because he
realizes that Tony Collette is uh she's
very depressed she could use some Sarah
muslin in that film [ __ ] love Tony
Collette have you seen Muriel's Wedding
lately not lately hey everybody within
the sound of my voice see Muriel's
Wedding it's really good
um uh God damn it's funny she was great
and hereditary yep she's waiting
everything I love love Tony Collette
and she later did she uh lulio's doing a
little stretch and he's showing his butt
his little bubble gum uh butthole to us
have a look see that I don't want to
look at it
Chad hates human bodies and the idea of
[ __ ] anyway really anything that is
floating orb that only thinks yes
doesn't sleep [ __ ] don't like the
physical world so in uh in this show
what's called by the way
uh baby doo-doo oh that's presented by
Taco Bell yeah yeah I think baby doo doo
presented by Taco Bell he brings the
little doo-doo Tom Brady yeah to uh a
support group for single parents who are
mostly uh women and uh in this support
group let's say they're all women just
for the sake of the show it'll be
interesting and girls are like what's
that smell what's that smell and he
finally has to let the cat out of the
bag and he's like I have a turd that's a
kid that's made out of [ __ ] yeah
here he is this is baby doo doo and uh
and then people like oh my God he smells
but he's so sweet he's so cute yeah hey
baby doo doo and then he meets a young
woman this will be a Crux of the show
yeah that he's a single guy he's meeting
women and and
um she she says she hooks up with them
after the meeting and says hey maybe we
could go get some coffee sometime I
could bring my little uh kid here you
know here's my little girl and he goes
man that's great what do you want to do
you want to go to Taco Bell yeah and
she's like no I don't like Taco Bell and
then he's like uh maybe we could go see
a Patriots game sometime yeah uh and
then they go to the Patriots game and
there's a Taco Bell stand at the
Patriots game and they get in a big
fight and I think that woman should be
played by Gisele Bundchen and um I will
also say this I think the pilot should
revolve around
Sheen has to enroll baby doo-doo in
school for the first time
and so I like that baby doodoo goes into
school and baby doo doo I think should
maybe start behaving badly and so Sheen
gets called like ah we're sorry your
your son is just like terrorizing other
kids bullying like there's all kinds of
problems and he finds out it's because
the other kids are bullying baby doo doo
they don't accept him and so in the end
Sheen has to get up in front of the
whole school at a PTA meeting and give a
huge speech
we were all baby dudus once yeah all of
us got bullied none of us are the same
everybody's different in some way but
don't let those differences separate us
that's what makes us stronger right and
everybody has to go give baby due to a
hug and at the end of the show all of
the parents all of the other kids are
walking out of the school covered in
[ __ ] I like because they've hugged baby
doo-doo yeah when I was a little boy my
dad said that I was a tiny piece of sh
it was a I was just a little piece of
[ __ ] he always used to call me a piece
of [ __ ] and I thought it was and and and
that was the abuse I suffered at my
father and I think it just deserts that
later I was uh my own child came out
wait was this Martin Sheen called a
piece of [ __ ] or is this in the world of
baby dude yeah no his dad in the show is
played by Alex Jones it's all flashbacks
oh great I actually love that you piece
of [ __ ] you know I don't wanna
this is a war this is a human war and
you're you're just a piece of [ __ ]
you're not ready to take on the
globalists you are a globalist get out
of my house go to Bohemian Grove and
then we find out in season two that Alex
Jones actually also had a baby doo-doo
Charlie Sheen has a brother that's made
of [ __ ] awesome it's Uncle doo-doo
thank you moving on Taco Bell used to
have
Taco Taco Bell used to have [ __ ] it all
right anyways
[Music]
please tell a friend then